The final type of memory loss that we're going to discuss is termed
absentmindedness. This is a form of forgetting that results from inattention.
Divided attention can lead to absentmindedness. So, if you're watching TV and
talking to a friend at the same time, that's going to lead to poor encoding of
either the content on the television show or the conversation you're having
with your friend. We're much less likely to remember things. If we're
multitasking. Now, again, it's really important to remember here that the more
we pay attention to what we're doing, the more likely we are to encode the
information correctly and retrieve it when necessary. So all those teachers
that told you you needed to pay attention, they weren't lying.